EMCEE: It's Colt
McAnlis, everyone.
COLT MCANLIS: Hello.
Good crowd today.
Are we on the videos up here?
No?
I'm going to stand awkwardly
live on the internet
for awhile.
How about that?
There we go.
Fantastic.
Hey, guys, really
quick, big round
of applause for Jake and
Paul for emceeing this thing.
Right?
[APPLAUSE]
COLT MCANLIS: It's
not every day you
get charismatic people able
to keep a crowd entertained
while the rest of
us babble on about
technical matters all day.
I am Colt McAnlis.
Hopefully my bald
attenuation comes before me.
By the way, really
quick before we talk,
because this is sort
of the first talk
I've done since the pirate talk.
How many people have
seen my pirate talk?
A round of applause.
The people on the
screen can't hear you.
[APPLAUSE]
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
That's it.
So the reason I ask that is
I've been approached by like six
people today, like, hey
what are you doing today?
Is today National Speak Like
a Carny Day or something?
What do you do?
And I have to tell
you the story.
After the pirate talk,
there was a serious memo
sent between my
managers, like, he's not
going to do something
crazy at Dev Summit, is he?
They were checking the
schedule, like, no, no.
It's just National Hello Day.
He can't screw that up.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Hey, guys,
thanks for your time today.
Thanks for listening so far.
I know that lunch
is on the horizon.
I'm going to try to keep you
entertained for the next 30
minutes here.
Really, #PERFMATTERS.
Yes?
A round of applause
for #PERFMATTERS.
You follow this?
You use this?
[APPLAUSE]
COLT MCANLIS: It
was a little weird
having Linus come up here and
be like, perf is everything.
And I'm like, oh crap.
I didn't work on my
slides that well.
So hopefully today we
can move through it.
I've said this before.
I'll say this a million times.
Today we're going to be talking
about tooling techniques
for the performance ninja.
If you see anything
that inspires you,
any fact, any statistic
you didn't know,
go to your social
media outlet of choice,
put #PERFMATTERS on
it, send it out today.
Keep the discussion going.
A year ago, think
about a year ago.
We didn't even have mobile
performance tooling.
That wasn't a thing.
And in a year, we've
actually sort of built
this community of angry,
angry web developers
who want better
performance on the web.
And really, that's
what today is about.
Because I think we can
all agree that mobile
is all that matters right now.
If you're not spending 90%
of your time optimizing
your mobile website for the
next five billion humans
that are going to be
coming on the web,
you're kind of
wasting your time.
So let's all just come
together [INHALING SOUND]
big, deep breath in, my
website is slow on mobile.
I accept it.
Come on.
Everyone say it.
No?
Nobody?
OK.
That's fine.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: That's right.
Self-denial.
It's a step.
You'll get there.
Don't worry.
It took me a little time.
I lost my hair,
it comes through.
Really, mobile is
all that matters.
And performance hasn't
been good on mobile,
and I think we all need to
be very blunt about that.
And I think one of
the reasons is this.
I love this quote by Ilya.
He said this in a blog
post a while ago--
"What you can measure,
you can optimize."
And this is really sort
of a telling thing.
Because if you think
about it, we really
haven't had the ability
to measure anything
in the mobile web.
Again, this time
last year we didn't
have the concept of
being able to get
data of a web page running
on a mobile device.
But thankfully,
today, with the help
of ADB extension
and Chrome DevTools,
we actually have the
ability to load a website
on a mobile device and actually
get the information back
into Chrome DevTools.
So you can get the same power of
your debugging on your desktop
and actually see the
performance characteristics.
Now this is good and bad.
It's good because
you have this power.
It's bad that everyone's
starting to know about this.
So if your website is slow,
there's no more excuses.
Sorry.
I actually had someone
come to my desk one day
and they're like, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
We have this power, so why
are websites still slow?
It's the internet, buddy.
So once you get the
ability to actually go
through this process
and actually get
these powerful tools giving you
the information that you need,
it's worth pointing out
that that's not enough.
So for those of you who aren't
versed in this repetitive
loop of performance
optimization,
you need to understand
that there's
three steps, three steps
to performance tooling.
And it starts at the basic
form, which is go get data.
If someone says, hey it's slow,
you've got go figure out why.
So you have to go use DevTools,
collect as much information,
and this usually ends
up being some sort
of huge sheet of
floating point numbers.
And this actually
goes into stage two.
A huge sheet of floating point
numbers really kind of sucks.
No one wants that, because
it doesn't tell you anything.
This goes into the
number two, which
is you have to gather insight
from that sheet of numbers.
You have to figure
out, wait a minute.
We're seeing all of these
waterfall characteristics,
and it's pointing at this
piece of data over here.
That's the insight.
Our site is slow because we have
too many megabytes on the wire.
That's causing
six-second load times.
That's why we're
about to go bankrupt.
Woe is me.
Of course, these
are the easy parts.
Chrome DevTools
can really help you
get far enough along in this.
And the really hard
part is stage three.
And anyone in here
who's dealt with this
realizes that the third
one, which is action,
is the hard part.
This is where you take all the
numbers and all the insight
and you go, wait a minute.
It's because we have this
five-megabyte GIF animating
on our main page that
we can't do this.
And you have to go over to
the designers and the artists
and you say, I
need this removed.
And they go, nope.
A round of applause if
that's happened to you.
Yeah?
[APPLAUSE]
COLT MCANLIS; See, I've
to keep you guys awake
before lunch gets here.
One guy in the back
is like, sandwiches!
This is really the tough part.
And probably the most
important part of this loop,
though, is actually
repeating it.
More times than, not
what you're going to find
is that your website does
not have a single performance
problem, but it has a plethora
of performance problems.
Uncovering one perf problem
and fixing it is not enough,
because chances are it
was hiding something else.
And once you've
unturned that stone,
you realize, oh wait a minute.
We've got an even bigger problem
that we need to fight below it.
Now once you sort of
realize that you're
going to have to continually go
through this process of gather,
insight, action, repeat,
gather, insight, action,
you start getting a sense that
the world is not that easy.
And what we're going
to talk about today
is only the gather
and insight parts.
You can go argue the action
parts with your web designers
later.
So when you're
doing this, you need
to come to the
understanding that there's
no longer a single pillar
of web performance.
Up until now, we've
really been talking
about networking, load time.
This has been the
currency that we've all
traded amongst our
web developer brethren
as the metric of
performance on our sites.
Hey, dude, how fast
does your website load?
Dude, two seconds, dude.
High five. [HIGH FIVING SOUND]
Anybody do that?
No one?
OK.
Maybe I'm in the wrong room.
But really what
we've been seeing
is how web apps have
developed, and the need,
and what users have demanded
from our web applications
have brought these other two.
The next one is render.
Linus stood on stage
today and said that.
Rendering is a performance
problem on mobile right now,
and we need to fix that.
And guess what?
Now we finally have tools that
allow you as the developer
to take control of your
rendering performance,
figure out the problems
that actually address them.
And then, of course,
the final one
is compute, network,
render, and compute.
Compute has been one of the
brethren of network over time.
JavaScript performance, you
see it over and over again.
Nowadays, VMs are so
fast and so powerful,
you generally don't see that.
Of course, once you put
it on a mobile device
and you get slower
compute speed,
you may run into some problems.
So I generally hate doing this.
I hate standing on
stage, and I hate
telling you, go fix
these three things.
But today I'm going to make
an exception, because I'm
particularly bald
and angry today,
and I figure I can get away
with stuff when I do that.
So here is your hit list.
We like to joke in the Perf
Squad that there's a hit list.
Like if we had a performance
assassin on your team
and he needed to take out three
things, these would be it.
So under the
networking list, you
should be optimizing
critical path.
And I know this is the tip
of the iceberg question.
We'll get into that in a minute.
For the render list, reduce
your number of paints.
And for compute, reduce
JavaScript execution time.
These are the things.
If you come away with
nothing from this talk
other than that angry
bald man yells loudly,
come away with
these three things.
This is where you need to
focus your performance time.
Now what we're going to do
for the rest of the talk
here is we're going to talk
a little bit about where
these things come
from and how we
can dive in to diagnose them.
So let's start with
network, load time.
Again, this is where we've been.
Unfortunately, "load time"
is a really bad, bad term.
Measuring your performance
of your network speed
by a load time is like
measuring your cholesterol
by how many doughnuts
you ate today.
It's an insanely
complex procedure
with many dependent
parts working together.
This is just one spec for
timing on just getting data
off the wire.
It doesn't even talk about
rendering or anything else.
So we actually have to change
our vocabulary a little bit
here.
And we could
actually probably use
a better term, which
is "critical path."
So it's not just about loading.
It's about what pixels are
needed to get to the screen.
So basically you
have a mobile device,
and it's kind of waiting around.
The user types in
some information.
That goes sent off
into the intertubules,
amongst all the cats and
everything else out there,
and it requests a site.
The site, of course,
is then going
to return some sort
of markup form.
Now what's going to happen here
is that your page says, cool.
I've got HTML.
Let me go start
parsing all this stuff
so that I can start painting.
Unfortunately, the web
isn't that way anymore.
All the content isn't just
contained in your HTML.
It's actually a complex
dance of other resources.
And so we can't
actually build our HTML
to start rendering yet.
Instead, we have to wait for
all of these other dependencies
to get resolved.
This is the critical path.
If you haven't heard
this term before,
this is the critical path.
It's the resolution of the
dependencies of your assets
to get the first
pixel on your screen.
Because if you have
JavaScript that you're
loading that's going to
affect how the DOM exists
or the CSS classes,
that's got to be present.
If you've got 50 CSS classes,
So this is what you
need to optimize,
is the number of dependencies
in your critical path.
And this really comes
from two to three places.
The first one is that, once we
put out a request like this,
you've got a lot of
dependencies to other resources.
The number of requests
that you send out there
actually has an implicit
overhead for each one of them,
which even gets worse
on mobile devices.
When you've got a 3G
network radio that's
spinning up and going through
cell towers and all sort
of other arcane magical
technologies that existed back
in the caveman days, that
we still have in our pocket,
oddly enough, that has
overhead associated with it.
So the more requests
you're doing,
the additional fat you're
adding to your time
for each one of those requests.
So if you're looking at
this, you need to say,
OK, one of our first
things we need to do
is reduce the number
of requests we're
doing to get assets, which
kind of comes back to the fact
that you have to reduce the
complexity of asset dependency
on your page.
I see some people sleeping.
Do I need to clap?
No.
Kidding.
I like that.
Who did that?
You get a t-shirt afterwards.
Everyone else is like,
I'm clapping now.
Free stuff.
Let's go to the second one here.
So once you've actually got
those requests out on the wire,
the next problem is page weight.
How fat are your assets.
And so I've kind of
done a lot of study
in this over the past couple
of months about compression
on the web.
Anyone read my series,
"Compression on the Web"?
More?
Yes?
[APPLAUSE]
COLT MCANLIS: I saw one dude
throw up the 10's in the back.
I like you, dude.
Two t-shirts.
The problem here
is that a lot of us
are still making
content for our website
as though you have a cable
internet connection, when
the reality is that
3G kind of sucks.
Linus stood on the stage
and said that earlier today.
Right?
We have assets
that are too large.
If your assets are too large
and the number of dependencies
you have are too
large, of course
it's going to keep your critical
path from being resolved.
So look at it from a
#PERFMATTERS side of it.
Reduce the number of
requests, and reduce
the size of the total
number of requests.
So what happens here is this, is
that once we get all this done,
we can finally get
to a point that we
can build our DOM and our
CSSOM or our Render Tree.
And then we can
resolve this chaos
and actually finally
start painting the page.
So the question for you then
is, if all of this chaos
is going on under the hood
that I have no idea about,
how do I use my
tooling to find it?
So let's take a look
at that really quick.
So this is The Verge.
It's a website.
It does some things.
I'm not going to go
too deep into that.
But most of you
already in the audience
here know the network tab.
So I've got The
Verge set up here.
It's actually loading
the mobile site.
We just hit reload here.
And you actually see
immediately what's going on.
Now I can dive deep,
deep, deep into this tool.
I think there's fantastic
resources out there
that get that done better.
And I've only got
30 minutes today,
so I'm going to give you
the high level one here.
So we're talking about
reducing critical path.
If we scroll, keep
scrolling, scroll all the way
to the bottom here, we see
there's about 90 requests
to get this site on the screen,
as well as 1.4 meg-- oh, it's
not even done.
Keep scrolling down.
1.4 megs of data.
OK.
Now for a mobile connection,
that's actually a lot of data.
How many of you are
in here from Europe
and other-- how many of you are
on roaming charges right now?
A round of applause
if you hate that.
[APPLAUSE]
COLT MCANLIS: A
round of applause
if you'd like to see
it less than 1.5 megs.
No.
It's okay.
We can take time.
It's cool.
We've got time.
I love confusing the audience.
They're like, wait.
Did we really want to do that?
I don't know.
And so the problem with
this is that all of this
has to get down before
we can do anything.
And so this is webpagetest.org.
Hopefully you guys
are using this.
And you run The Verge
through webpagetest.org,
you go down here
into waterfall view,
and you can see that
this green line--
everybody see this
green line over here?
Yeah?
This green line represents
when the page painting occurs.
Anything before this
green line represents
assets and
dependencies that have
to be resolved before we can
put a pixel on the screen.
So now look at this.
What is this?
We keep scrolling down.
It looks like we've
got maybe-- I'm
just going to give it to them
here and say about 60 assets.
That's 60 requests on the wire.
I don't have the sizes of
all of these assets here.
But that's 60 requests that
had to go out there and get
resolved for it put a
pixel on the screen.
Let's look at something
that's a little bit better.
Granted, it's a
different example.
But this is m.lanyard.com,
all props to Jake Archibald.
And so we just hit reload here.
And was that one request?
No.
There we go.
This example is too good.
So you can see as a very
different pace, this version
of the mobile site is actually
23 requests and about 125 K.
Still able to get to your data.
And I understand there's
a design principle
difference between
these two sites,
but you want to get it low.
And with the networking tab,
you can figure this out.
And when you look over here
at webpagetest details,
you can actually see that
that green line actually
comes in at about 0.9 seconds.
Look at this.
We have maybe one,
two, three assets,
three assets that had to
be downloaded and resolved
before the critical
path can start painting.
That's the website you
want your users to load,
because that's
where the money is.
All right.
We're running out of time.
I got to keep hurrying here.
So once you resolve the
chaos, we get networking done.
Here's the thing-- I am just
the Ghost of Christmas Present.
My job here is not
to inform you guys.
My job is to set up these
brave and awesome and smart
gentlemen.
More information will
be brought to you
at this conference from Ilya
on performance networking,
as well as Bryan on creating
instant mobile apps.
So now let's talk
about rendering.
So we've got a bunch
of cat pictures.
We want to deliver the cat
pictures in a friendly cat
picture way, because it's a cat
picture world that we live in.
And we have to paint it.
So the cool thing is
that a lot of people
didn't know until earlier this
year that painting on a web
page was not free.
So there's actually
a software resource.
Something has to happen.
So the user actually puts
his finger on your site,
and he starts scrolling around.
And what happens is, we
have to translate the page.
And then what's not
visible to the page,
we have to actually
spin up the CPU
and spend cycles
rasterizing that content.
And this keeps occurring.
The user scrolls.
We have to rasterize content.
Now there's a good talk.
You can see the
link on the bottom
here where we talk about
the interdependency
between the CPU and the GPU.
I won't get into that today.
But the point that
you need to take away
is that scrolling isn't the
only place that painting occurs.
There's other
things that the user
does that causes paints as well.
For example, let's
say you have your DOM,
and the DOM's doing awesome,
and it's a DOMmy-DOM day.
And the user clicks
on something,
and you're like,
dude, free stuff!
And you have to actually
pop up a dialogue
to say, dude, free stuff!
And in doing so,
you modify the DOM.
Well when you
modify the DOM, all
of the properties of the
DOM have to be recalculated,
because we have to
figure out did you
change something
that was visible.
When you do this, we have
to rebuild everything,
which means things on
the screen have changed,
which means we need to
actually repaint things.
So when you change the DOM, you
update properties to the DOM,
repaints have to occur.
Another great example.
So let's say we've got a user
who's scrolling your site.
And a lot of mobile
websites I see nowadays
use CSS properties to
sort of store state.
So you've got some
piece of code here
that's like, the user
is scrolling now.
Let's add this class to the
DOM that represents sticky.
We want a sticky header.
Anyone do this?
Don't raise your hand.
Don't.
Stop.
You're about to
find out-- don't.
Just don't raise your hand.
I'm giving you a warning.
What's good is on
the live stream
they can't see this direction,
so they don't see this.
What happens is, every time
you modify the class list,
the CSS object model
has to be rebuilt.
And, of course, this
causes a repaint.
So you touch the DOM.
You touch CSS.
Repaints have to occur.
We call this "paint
storming" if you
get into a weird cycle of this.
So let's take a
look at a demo here.
Single demo-- this
is super easy.
Paul Irish did a fantastic
video of this earlier this year.
I just want to show what he did.
So this is scrolling a site.
And I'm just kind of
scrolling slowly here,
but you can see it's actually
just a little jittery.
I'm not sure how well this
is coming on the stream.
But you can see some
of these white boxes
here just aren't
moving too well.
And so when -- hold on.
Doing live demos is awesome.
If we actually get
recording on the timeline
here and start
scrolling, we can see
sort of a plethora of
these green and purples.
And what we're effectively
looking at here
is, when you see green and
purples on the timeline view,
these are recalc
styles of layout.
So this is exactly what
we were talking about.
We have some event going on.
When you mouse over them,
you get to go down here
and say, hey here's the
call stack that caused this.
And lo and behold, here
is a JavaScript function
that's intermixed
between the jQuery
that the user developers of
this website actually wrote
and you can see here.
Basically what
they're doing-- let
me see if I can zoom that
in just a little bit.
What they're doing here is,
every time the user scrolls,
they're toggling a class
based upon some heuristic.
So every single
mouse scroll, they're
updating the CSS tree, which
then has to be rebuilt,
which then causes a repaint.
And we're seeing this here
in the timeline as well.
Boom.
Scroll, recalculate, layout,
paint, paint, paint, paint,
paint.
And now this actually
is pretty bad.
This is 7 milliseconds
on my desktop here.
We get into some
pretty gnarly places
where this is 10 milliseconds.
Down here it looks like we've
got some big, thick purples.
Big, thick purples.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Seven
milliseconds there.
We're live on the internet guys.
Simmer down.
So the point here is
that you can actually
use the timeline
view to find out
what's causing these recalcs
and paints on your page.
So want more info?
jankfree.org.
These are the jank-busters.
These are the guys who
invented the term "jank."
Go follow them.
They got a talk a
little bit later.
Tom Wiltzius and
Nat Duca, they'll
give you all the
details you need
to make silky smooth
rendering performance.
So let's go to my
favorite area, compute.
This is the thing that
I live and thrive on.
So let's say 16
milliseconds a frame.
You have 60 frames a second.
It means you have
16 milliseconds.
But the funny thing is, you
don't have 16 milliseconds.
The browser has 16 milliseconds.
You have to share.
Remember your mom and
your dad taught you
that when you were
a kid, like, hey
you can't have your whole
time with the truck.
You've got to trade
the truck with Chrome.
Chrome needs time
with the truck,
and then you can
have the truck back.
And you're ilke, I want my time.
And Chrome's like,
I want my time.
Anyhow, the point is that
you don't have fully 16
milliseconds to
do all your work.
When you get a rAF event,
Chrome's doing other stuff.
Including that other
stuff is a paint event.
It actually has to
branch off and go
do painting and compositing
and all this other stuff.
And that's intermixed
with all the JavaScript
that you're trying to
run for your application.
So what happens is,
every 16 milliseconds
you'll get a rAF pulse,
and this is fine,
until something happens in your
code that actually pushes back
this designated work that
Chrome's going to do anyway.
And when that happens, you miss
that 16th frame and your rAF
skips.
And this is known
as a skipped frame.
This is when users feel jank.
Now I know we're talking
about a rendering
problem in the compute
section, but bear with me now.
So the question is, what caused
that JavaScript to get slow?
We need to make sure that
we keep an eye on this.
60 frames a second means
16 milliseconds a frame.
You have to play nice, share.
So let's say you've got a cool
game like Super Resident Raver,
and you're going along
doing some cool touch stuff.
Touch Handler occurs, and you
just do a flood of things.
The user touched.
So I need to go through and
order a pizza, because I'm
hungry right now, and
update 10 million zombies,
because they're going
to attack the pizza,
and they're going to be
doing cool stuff, too.
Well, the problem with this is
that you miss your rAF target.
And, of course,
the next rAF would
want to come immediately
at that point.
But, again, it has
to skip a frame.
So the problem here
is that you end up
doing too much work
in a single frame,
and you can end up
pushing it back.
Another problem is probably
a little bit more complex,
and I've done some talks
about this in the past.
But let's say you've got
just a ton of stuff going on.
By the way, if anyone
sends me source code
of an HTML5 game they
make that implements
all of those gestures at once,
I will send you free stuff.
I just want to put
that out there.
But let's say you've got 90
hands on a game right now,
and this is actually causing
a lot of allocations.
What can actually occur is
that during your update phase,
garbage collection can occur any
time garbage collection feels
like it needs to occur, which
can push out your update loop,
because it needs time to go.
And it's a
single-threaded model,
which is then going
to put your draw back,
which again is going
to put your rAF back.
So I've got a little
bit of time here.
I want to finish
up on a high note.
So, actually, not
to Paul Lewis yet.
He's bald.
OK.
So I want to show you
what this looks like.
So if you're trying to track
down performance issues
from compute-- here's
Super Resident Raver--
there's two tools you
need to check out.
First off is collecting
a JavaScript CPU profile.
So I'm not going
to play the game.
I'm just going to
hit start here.
Well OK, maybe I'll
make some stuff happen.
OK.
Things are going-- yes.
Good.
People are running around.
Chaos ensues.
Fantastic.
And I'm going to let that
dude run around and get
eaten by zombies for a second.
But what you can
actually see down here,
and this is one of my
favorite things added
to Chrome DevTools-- is
this is a flame chart, which
effectively shows me
where all of my calls
are going for a given frame.
So I can actually see,
hey wait a minute.
Where is my time
going in my frame?
Who's responsible for it?
What's the function
that's taking that time?
This allows me, again, to
measure where my content is
going and update it accordingly.
The second thing
you need to look
at when you're dealing
with memory issues
is actually this record
heap allocations.
Now for HTML5 game
developers, this
is fantastic, because
you can kind of just
hit Start and sit back.
Now for those of you who
aren't versed in this tool,
it's actually fantastic,
because it sort of melds
heap allocation tracking
with a timeline view.
So what you're seeing
at the top there
is allocations that have
been allocated and freed.
Some of them are still
resident on the stack.
You can see that in blue.
Some of them have been freed,
and you can see that in gray.
And then you can find a specific
portion here and actually drill
down and say, hey,
wait a minute.
What was actually
created during that frame
to create those allocations?
And if you're
lucky, sometimes you
can actually figure
out where in your code
it actually came from.
So here I could see
that the fade timer
stream was actually created.
It was probably passed off
to some anonymous function
that needed work done to it.
So with all of these
tools, you kind of
start getting the sense
that you can actually
measure what's going on
in your mobile universe.
You can actually
get to the data.
You can actually figure
out what's going on,
take ownership of your website
performance, and move forward.
I love this quote by
Paul Lewis-- "Tools.
Not rules."
Anyone who stands
on the stage at this
point-- Well OK, let's
roll back for a minute.
About a year and
a half ago, people
would give performance
advice, but there
wasn't enough information
on the client side
to actually give that advice.
Like, hey, your
scrolling is slow.
Well how?
Well I don't know.
I kind of tossed some
chicken bones around
and it said it was slow.
Sweet.
Chicken bones.
But now we have the
tools, and now you
need to move towards
that methodology.
Validate everything
you're seeing.
Measure it.
Go forward with
that methodology.
Don't just rely on a bunch
of bald people standing
on stage telling you
what to optimize.
Go find it in your tool
chain in your application
and fix it there.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
Go to HTML5 Rocks if you want
to become a performance guru.
Check out the slides
in the other talks
we've been talking about today.
Here's how you get a
hold of me, #perfmatters.
Thank you for your time today.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]